do you mind going back in time with me
and playing my favorite game let's do it
it's behind
[Applause]
the high school there's drooling save
the last time oh my goodness
oh my gosh so what I learned something
so amazing from Julia Stiles I mean I
learned so much from Julia because she
had done a bunch of films this was my
first Studio film and um one day it was
really really really cold we were
shooting in Chicago in the winter so
cold and we're having these really cute
outfits they weren't very warm they were
just very very cute and the director was
like one more time one more time one
more time our brilliant wonderful
director Thomas Carter and finally Julia
said I'll do it as many times as you
want when you take off your coat
and he said
waffle and then we
[Applause]
then it's so good
so good wow right I love that I love
that all right Ray oh my goodness this
film is so incredible
I just have to say like people will
often compliment me on the kind of
number one that I am when you when you
go to work in Showbiz there's a call
sheet and the lead character is the
number one on the call sheet and you
find that however the number one acts
everybody else kind of takes their cues
for how to be on set and when people say
that I'm a good number one if that's
true I always say I owe it all to Jamie
because he is the best number one on the
call sheet ever ever ever
[Applause]
I love that story yeah all right I love
this film so much I've seen it way too
many times Mr and Mrs Smith is so fun
the thing I loved the most is that I
learned to rock climb for that film
because there was a scene she and I are
climbing the rock and talking about
talking casually yes and so we took rock
climbing together and we actually shot
it on this giant styrofoam plastic wall
that looked like rocks in like a parking
lot of an Ikea but it looks like like
we're in this gorgeous mountain in the
middle of nowhere yeah all right Django
Unchained this is a beloved bulb yeah
what was going on there I mean I I will
say there is a scene people often ask me
if this if this is true and it is true
there was a scene where Leonardo
DiCaprio who's so brilliant in the film
actually smashed glass and had a bloody
hand and did the scene finished the
scene with a bloody hand and so in the
scene he goes to touch my face later and
Quentin wasn't sure if he wanted to use
the take with the blood or not so every
moment after that moment in the movie we
shot twice we would shoot completely
bloody with him touching my face with
fake blood
um and then we had to take everything
off and shoot it again totally clean
because you just wanted to have the
option in the edit of blood or no blood
and Quentin Tarantino I mean I love him
so much yeah
incredible things into the world yeah
okay
scandal
[Applause]
I don't even know what to say about her
you know she just she totally changed my
life you know she really did
um I think in a lot of ways she taught
me a lot about how to be a leader you
know she used to say it's my name on
that door and in some ways it was like
it was my show like I had to have that
same sense of responsibility and feeling
like I could lead something and I think
playing her helped me fool myself into
thinking that I could and you can and
that's the point of characters giving
you an emboldened nature that sometimes
we can't give ourselves it's so strange
yeah it's like that um I have a friend
who says fake it till you make it you
know and sometimes characters give you
the permission to do that it's so true
sometimes you just gotta wake up and put
on the bold red lip and then you might
feel sexy as the day goes on yeah you
know exactly yeah
and lastly
we could not love this more also little
fires everywhere
good I just love Reese Witherspoon so
much I just love her so much and we had
so much fun like getting in the ring
with each other because we're actually
like beloved friends we adore each other
and so the days where we would have our
big character fights it was ever there
was like all buzz on set like everybody
was going to watch a big match and we'd
like really have to rev up to battle
each other on camera and it was just so
fun to be able to play that way with a
good friend and we'd do the scene and
then we'd look at each other and be like
we can be worse you know and we'd go
again it was so fun oh my God I love it
well it really paid off
[Music]
foreign